this episode of fighter and the kids
with adam ray man
a few housekeeping notes before we get
into the shenanigans
san marcos texas 10 tickets left total
for all four shows
get tickets at f a t k z dot com or t
tfatk.com wherever you want to get them
also thick boy specialized collab is out
thickies get on it these will sell out
they're limited edition
uh it's kind of like that dry fit
material that's why they're a little
more expensive but they
are dope short sleeve long sleeve water
bottles
big boy smiley specialized collab is
there
it just got posted this morning so as
you listen to this head on over to
thickboy.com
for the specialized collab this episode
is brought to you by audit the one
supplement that i stand behind
on it supplements what do you need alpha
brain total gut health
earth grow nutrients krill oil we got
protein powder creatine we got it all
for your thick ass
right now get in shape it's 20 21 get
in shape man you need workout gear we
got your kettlebells
on demand workouts club maces home
fitness programs you don't have to go to
the gym
do it from your phone on it in 30
kettlebell 130 moving groove on at 6
streaming fitness
uh from your phone man do it in your
garage do it in your underwear
body weight durability steel club steel
mace barbell we got it all
on at 6 streaming fitness for your thick
ass
battle ropes go to onit.com fighter for
off the entire goddamn side i just told
you about again that's on it.com
fighter mr
[Music]
wake up early in the morning press play
and let's get it in cause we rocking
with the fighter and he rolling with the
kids
you and he breaks down some [ __ ] yeah
see
man from g's to jets in the house
oh yeah you still got the du-rag on we
rolling are we rolling you yeah we run
coming but show the waves yeah show the
audience uh
because it's infuriating well they these
are again this is a nice insulin man's
bro
don't say that come on now here we go
i'm standing up for the audience for the
the audible get them roly-poly legs out
thank you man but now are those ski
pants they're not ski
you just can't have super white socks
like that that's cool
with the kobe what yeah you got it i
thought it was an adidas sock
wait no no no no no adidas make socks
like they do
it's a real pet peeve of mine my girl
tried walking out of the house with
adidas shoes and nike socks
you corrected and they're gonna
represent me girl you represent
that's the thing about it bro it's nike
there's circulation there's air
circulation bro it's not even the
pressure i get what you're saying but
not it's a collab distinction nike
collab
and bro these are go these now here's
the thing i think i got a too big of a
size because when
you see me in it they look like my size
they look like yours like it's thick boy
yeah my representing the brain yeah it
makes your legs look you look like
you look like a water boy at a rat
battle
[Laughter]
everybody who starts to
when i looked at him i was like bro i
would never yeah i don't think i would
and look in a stussy jacket with it
that [ __ ] jacket goes hard as [ __ ]
thank you that's yeah yeah
yeah so juicy fell off for a second when
i was a kid they were big
they were they still yeah well they came
back no no no there's a while
right they were like only in target oh
yeah i remember that walmart yeah but
that's remember champion champion in the
same way
i know once you go that direction it
gets dicey wait wait you rock champions
uh champion made some dope [ __ ] like
they have cool collabs with uh todd
snyder and [ __ ]
who's that todd snyder's uh uh designer
you ever seen todd science [ __ ] i wreck
some todd steiner dude i'm trying to get
up on the face i wear the same
[ __ ] dude i mean the shoes oh
makeover dude yeah what do you think i
need something
but you know what my thing is i stress
out and this is why i wear the same [ __ ]
pants
i stress out over pants yeah and like i
i like
i don't know like it's hard to like go
like i remember i would try to go to h
m i was like oh some of this shit's cool
but i can't i can't figure it out i'll
give you a list of stores
you can't go into there's certain stores
oh look
at the man that's cool
i know but i know you know where i'm at
you don't know what exactly
i don't know all right so the problem is
yeah
you're going through the wrong stuff you
know all saints not pants pants
are nightmare force but all saints have
some like bigger sizes
yeah yeah there was there no you you
showed me one like pants
uh the door doers oh do it yeah or
whatever
you'll fit g like these are g these are
my favorite stars g-star
because they have like bobby schmerker
like they have what's your ways they
have a flex on them what's up what's
your waist i have to get
38 pants yeah because my thighs
damn why are you my biggest
yeah speculation that's not proven but
the thighs i can see
but anyways 38 otherwise ain't gonna
feel that's what i'm saying dude that's
my world
otherwise they're not going to [ __ ]
what atlanta are you like 38 are you the
day of devitos 38 30's or some [ __ ] yeah
30's yeah
i don't think my legs i mean yeah it's
just my thoughts yeah you got big guys
yeah dude they always they've always
been like just [ __ ] big yeah
but my like my legs like like you guys
are fine you got a body like legs
you know because you don't really wear
jeans you just wear like those those
black khakis or uh tan khakis right yeah
well there's like the jogger i got it
from dude yeah joggers yeah yeah yeah
they're australian i don't know what
they are they have some nice dudes
sounds french
yeah yeah but uh but yeah man that's i
wanna
yeah let's do this you want some jeans
you you want like uh like blue jeans
cause you guys come in here with the
fresh shirts
yeah don't get me wrong i'm always good
like this is a drip never stopped yeah
you have you ever just made me laugh so
hard and joey
in uh tiger king you know he's not
getting out of prison he's [ __ ] but
on like ready to go he was like my
makeup in here yeah they got a limo
everything's ever so sad they still
waiting they still waiting it's never
happening it's never happening
the best the best part of tiger king is
when that
lady gets her arm ripped off by a tiger
oh my god bro
his first instinct was like let me go
grab
this swaggy coat yeah oh yeah
and then his next his first thought is
not about the girl got her arm
bitten off by tiger he went to the club
his first thing was oh let me get this
dope ass empty
jacket because the drip don't stop
dripping stuff and the second thought
went
i'm never really i'm never going to
financial recovery
he made it just about him he's trying to
vote yeah
yeah she's on
the funniest thing is he saw her he was
like yeah arm off let me go to the dr
the gift shop so yeah he was drip shot
oh
we're gonna have to shut things down you
know
this jacket was swaggy how swag was that
jacket though oh
bro well he you know he had his own
fashion nah so yeah he was killing it
yeah
so crazy is he got them dudes straight
dudes
straight dudes that one dude from okay
got like the tall kid from oklahoma he
got them to marry him
dude you do butt stuff and then the one
dude his main
main dude the dude with like the tattoos
with the stomach tattoo bro
the god smack tattoo on his tummy right
there oh the guy with the the tv
he has veneers now and a fiancee no he
doesn't he got veneers now yeah he's
killing the [ __ ]
piece are you serious yeah chin bring
him up bring that dude up
young young young
tired king boyfriend is engaged or
married and has veneers
what's up dog bracket what up jake oh
you're a brooklyn nets fan now hi
you're from you're from seattle you're
from seattle bro
good to see you i am from seattle so uh
we're waiting for kevin durant to uh to
come back
yeah is that what yeah that's the next
jersey kevin seattle supersonics do you
have that jersey
i don't i got a sean cam jersey i got a
uh deadlift shrimp jersey
oh dead lifts him shoes the kamikazes
yeah yeah he was like nine kids yeah
interviewed him yeah at his weed store
in seattle yeah oh [ __ ] he's opening he
has a restaurant he used to have a
bar restaurant too you have a bar uh
called oscars that everybody would go
get [ __ ]
i saw him there on new year's and he was
just [ __ ] up and i was like dude you
were my childhood hero he was like i was
everybody's hero i was like yeah we
chest bumped
and uh and i was like this will never be
topped and then we went to his weed
store and uh chatted for like two hours
because those shoes were the [ __ ]
in line yeah i'm everybody's here but
also i'd say
take it easy yeah all right but if you
own a bar in the city where you did
[ __ ] hold down the 90s in the city
like i would be screaming oh it's like
dude i remember i was deep throating
a big jumbo shrimp cocktail i was i was
yeah but you don't have to say no
i can't emphasize enough dude by the way
there's
you should open a restaurant where every
type of food is like some sort of like i
was d
like you can get the deep throat shrimp
or you can get that size
you want the the foot long the deep
throat
how big is the deep throat uh chicken
tender can i get a deep throat
but i was i was i'm engulfing this
[ __ ] jumbo shrimp at elway steakhouse
and he walked in
my word what did you get some fella oh
yeah dude he's a unicorn in denver
he's he's damn he runs that place yeah
he's yeah he's got car dealerships too
doesn't doesn't
he sold he that's where he made all his
money because when he was playing he had
a bunch of elway auto
autonation i think yeah and they were
everywhere so you couldn't
get away from elway and then he sold him
for like a gillion dollars
but i remember he was the first one if
you remember in the night i think it was
like 93 maybe
when the dodge viper first came out he
was the first one to have it
dude and he we and not me my dad saw him
driving
with my brother and wearing my dad's
bronco we flipped the [ __ ]
out yeah have you ever seen uh dodge
viper yeah
and he's about every bit of six four six
five yeah so it's a convertible at the
time
his head was over the top like this
perfect still look cool
he was like yo i'm gonna deep throat
that shrimp right now
all right
it is it is a crazy thing to think about
when you see uh an athlete that is up on
a pedestal
for you like that the first time out in
public off the court of the field right
what's up it's like when you see your
teacher in the grocery store so weird
it's so should i invited my third grade
teacher to my little league game because
i had a crush on her yeah
and i don't know yeah but she brought a
dude and i remember
even at 10 being like i didn't say there
was a plus one [ __ ]
i'm sorry
oh
yeah i was butt hurt dude damn it's so
weird because i thought i'd put my head
because also you know i didn't have
enough social awareness to be like
she's not coming if she does come which
was crazy she even showed up
obviously respect looking back in
hindsight good move to bring somebody
because if she just showed up solo
everyone's like who's that
is that the new mary kayla turtle like
why is she coming solo
oh adam invited me like no we get that
we got that did you bring muffins
is there a food to dilute the pervy-ness
yeah i'm sorry did you bring
cut up orange slices at half time
is it so funny even just a baked good
yeah would make her seem like
you're good you can have one tit out if
you have some [ __ ] cupcakes you're
good
orange slices that's strange i've never
seen my teacher at the grocery store
you're like oh
[ __ ] that's so awkward yeah hey who was
the teacher
uh her name was mrs familaro yeah and i
had such a big crush on her
wow so you had hot teachers um
she was like my teacher from like
kindergarten through fourth
yeah i mean she talks about sex like all
the teachers guys oh
that's the worst if the sex ed teacher
is one who you know is currently [ __ ]
oh like a lot because then she's just
really she's like you can put the condom
on you know or you don't have to and
you're like wait what
she's like some people some people you
can put it on like this yeah
or you can just [ __ ] go go for it so
you can go for it and risk it that's way
fun
on the street they call it raw dog
uh mrs holbert was a spanish teacher and
um
she was like the high school teacher
that was you know once i think the mary
kay eternal thing happened it was like
all right
now now you think about in your world
right like who are the teachers that
could be
you know not that you're thinking for
yourself but like you're like oh i
wonder if like
because miss holberg definitely i saw
the way she interacted with some
seniors when i was a sophomore and i was
like dang somebody if it's not happening
it should like that's the guy like
there's a kid named kenye tillman
who wore no shirt in overalls and i had
a mustache
[ __ ] yeah dude had everything yeah
what's up oh just if it was gonna happen
it was probably that kid
yeah this strange i remember thinking
back on it now when i see like those
stories pop out of teachers hooking up
with the students i'm like man that
my teacher's all pretty brutal like oh
then i
but i remember when i was uh playing
football at university colorado
there there was this uh i think they
call them
uh sponsors you see the sponsors or
i forget boosters and they would always
they yeah the boosters and they would
donate all the money to the program
yeah and i remember there's this one
rich white lady whose husband passed
away
and she always had these three black
guys hanging all the time bernard
jackson this quarterback
good looking feller went to uh jail for
uh robbing a person anyway great guy but
he
and her they were always together and i
remember like we just be talking to you
rubbing his shoulders into my head i'm
like oh that's weird
i wonder i wonder where bernard got the
new jordans
what he did for those you know there's
always those little uh physical uh
hints too that you don't look pick up on
in the moment like all those little
shoulder rubs and back rubs
smile at each other oh yeah yeah like
just a smile or he says something that's
not even funny and she's laughing real
hard
yeah yeah yeah yeah
he's throwing a perfect attendance he's
like here i bet you are yeah
i think well i ran out of chalk i have a
tough time finding chalk past 8 p.m
these teachers that are getting caught
now they're pretty hot yeah they bad i
it's the every time i see a roja teacher
i mean it's just what everybody thinks
you're just like man how cool was that
kid
oh because like i mean i don't know how
at 12 and 13 yeah what did he say i
know i had no game like i can't even
think about
and maybe also again to go back to that
point maybe
it doesn't happen for these kids to even
start thinking about trying to
spit game until it happened right maybe
you're not even thinking because when i
was in
elementary school high school i didn't
even think of that as a possibility
until the eternal thing came out and
then my eyes that's why i was like
oh [ __ ] that kid's probably definitely
doing it so uh
so yeah but the teachers every time you
see a mug shot even the mug shot you're
like
i mean i get it and also they're like
these teachers are predators
these kids are victims yeah you go talk
to that kid he's like
that's pretty cool wasn't there one that
got a train run on her oh
yeah yeah two boys and they came out it
was recent right yeah right
they always get caught from the parents
because parents were like you know
they're eating dinner like
look over the phone like is that mrs d
is that my steam with her tits oh you
know
damn well think about that that's like i
mean i think about that now when i see
just
you know instagram pages with just
you know everything and i'm like not i
mean
i don't have kids but even with like my
nieces as young girls
when i see some of these pictures pop up
or like the teachers i'm like god damn
dude that
who is that that's the girl right there
i don't know it says multiple people so
multiple students multiple students what
is multiple
by the way if it was a couple you'd say
a couple
multiple might be double digits oh three
counts
that sounds like a full classroom yeah
um
well what happens is i'm sure she hooks
up with like andy
andy tells dave dave's like well hey man
yeah let me i gotta get mine so i'm
gonna go tell she's like all right fine
she's like you think i'm cool you should
go [ __ ] with baron yeah
yeah he smells better than i do yeah
i'm just saying he wears clothes but
also i [ __ ] up and
told him and he said he's going to
snitch on us if you don't suck them up
oh man you think they started bargaining
they would have to right
they're turning teachers together but
like the thing is like how does the
first guy get it
what is his game whoa teacher god have
an orgy click on that chin
north texas it's a video yeah there's
graphic yeah click on it yeah all right
let's see
can i sign something first not in my
opinion
they didn't feel like i victimized them
they didn't feel like victims
you know oh she's only sure they don't
feel like victims now
you're watching the most [ __ ] and
informative
lrj tv news i wish i had me a teacher
like that
dude that is the guy who should be
hosting every
crime show news show the walking dead
that's so funny that's hilarious that
doesn't matter
man she's not hot though she was honored
oh she was like oh you why don't you ask
them if they felt victimized yeah
she was putting it on her yeah she looks
better
yeah i mean did you guys see the show on
hulu called teacher
that uh just came out oh man it's
basically about
is it real or no no but it's all um it's
you'll recognize both the actors but
it's a teacher in the small town and
and uh yeah it's called a teacher and
basically it's just it's
series i think 10 abs and and it's about
that it's about like the
uh the parents and she gets fired and
[ __ ] you know
really chastised and that kid's a great
actor too oh yeah
there's something sexy and she and
totally and she's not he's in high
school i think he's a
senior and and they just but they're
like in love and she's got
a husband though and trying to have a
kid oh this is that story yeah
it might be actually it might be based
on a true story sure
it sounds fantastic yeah it's great and
it's also like
that's the guy from bad driver correct
yeah yeah okay cool all right he's also
in another movie where he he's gay and
he comes out to his family
yeah it's really good yeah simon yeah
simon there it is yeah yeah he's dope
and i mean he crushes it and it's
oh this isn't it says it's not based on
a specific true story but i mean
stories are probably similar to that for
sure yeah yeah there was one where like
i think
the student ended up killing the husband
or something like that oh that gets done
so yeah yeah we're not like
i was hoping for it to take a turn like
that and then have that guy come back in
that was some crazy [ __ ]
ryan won't do all that didn't see that
coming
have you been here though during the
whole pandemic so uh we went and hung
out with sean cam when i hung out with
sean camp
um was supposed to go to uh austin
tomorrow i think i still am to do
um some of those chapelle shows but uh
he got kovit yeah yeah so that's that's
probably on the back burner
but uh no i went to seattle for a little
bit to see the fam then went to arizona
with uh my girl for her fam uh to do
that and then did shows there
because that was kind of the first place
it was open um you said in arizona
yeah where'd you stand up live live
tempe and then cv live i think i was
there when you guys when you were there
right
oh yeah i was headlining tempe yeah
because derek told me he went to kick
with you guys i was like where's the
[ __ ] invite
um but uh and then went to you know i
did minnesota in like july
and uh minnesota up their acne was up
and it was real limited though so it was
like
usually i think that room holds maybe
250 it was like
capped at 70. but at this point this was
july and i was just trying to get work
i i just wanted to perform too man i
literally didn't give a [ __ ] i was like
i want i need some live shows
i've done you know enough uh you know
outdoor things that i just wasn't doing
it man and i just uh
yeah and i just didn't care and i uh and
uh and i loved that club
and um and some things were open too and
i'd been in places that just weren't
that
open and um but uh gonna go to i think
nashville
after austin for a few days and then
back to seattle for a while and then
probably stay there for a minute
yeah my folks get in the vaccine and oh
they are they're freaking out my mom i
mean
they're the type and they should be
concerned because they're just
they're around i think everyone's
comfort level is based on like
how much you consume from the tube and
the web as far as like
like my stepdad would be like can i just
hear the story some guy in new york city
was uh there's a great impression by the
way
my stepdad george who uh great guy uh
had a paper route since he was 10
uh you know worked at morgan stanley
just retired uh
asked me took me to a sonic's game
against the lakers to ask me if he could
ask my mom to marry him that's cool
oh yeah and even he turns me one point
so yeah oh she brought you here i wonder
if
i just i love your mom i want to know if
i if i can ask you permission because
you've made a house by getting married
and i was like
i don't think so george just to [ __ ]
with him and he goes
oh shot there okay [ __ ] and i was like
okay
oh dude bought me a laptop for college i
was like you're set dude put it in every
hole but oh
good dude yeah he's a great dude but um
but uh
but so he's like man i heard the
destroyer guy who's running in new york
and
a guy who was jogging by him and bumped
his elbow and he got covered and died
and i was like all right i'm gonna need
a little bit more backstory today
yeah yeah or i believe every part of it
but um but again they just
if you just watch the news it's totally
it's the craziest thing because i've had
friends though that were like
man not in bad shape that like took a
real so so again it's like based on
what you what's around you right yeah
it's your perspective right
like i've you know i got it my whole
family got it so my perspective is
wasn't that big of a deal
but then we do have uh super close
family friends whose son got it and
passed away
and he was only 22. but whole
caveat here he was 375. okay thank you i
was
so that's sorry but in my head i was
like please tell me you should have
started with
really big yeah like no that's right
well that because i didn't know them
you know i i know the the mom and dad
they're my mother-in-law and
father-in-law's best friends
and like oh i think whatever his name
timmy got it and i was like
oh isn't he and i asked my grandma isn't
he like really out of shape she was
yelling
that's that's where you get in trouble
yeah obesity oh yeah it [ __ ] you up
yeah if you have underlying health
conditions you're like really big if
you're young you get it you're in
trouble
yeah that vaccine if you're in shape
because you bombs back yeah oh yeah
everyone i know who's been shaped is
fine yeah yeah yeah the vaccine should
come with some sort of like diet plan or
like a packet of crystal light like
something just yeah
like just just a light just to encourage
here's a 30-day membership you know they
open up
are you guys going to get it oh we
already talked about this
oh no i'll do literally whatever it
takes to open up
what dude cool i love that yeah if i
have to suck off the doctors
well that was my next question how many
doctors will you suck
to get la county open whatever it takes
where's our suck-off camera
okay i think it's right tell the people
knew something
i love that you knew who to address yeah
mr governor news yeah
listen are you going to get it i think
so yeah i mean
yeah i uh i don't know you've already
known people to get it yeah i have two
yeah that aren't uh that aren't like
uh and the media is [ __ ] up [ __ ] up
because forever it's like
we just need a vaccine assuming we have
vaccine we're going to go another
vaccine's out there like well some
people are on side effects like you
you're [ __ ] you you're literally
[ __ ] up the narrative and now
people see that they're scared of the
vaccine we can't move forward
because those people with issues are the
exception yeah
i don't know and i also we're on
lockdown because of the exception
man i think i'm waiting for somebody to
come because like you know they show
obama like everyone's getting it and
like until like if obama got on camera i
was just like you know
yeah i'm telling you and then and then
just [ __ ] went palsy like i'd be like
all right i'm probably gonna
i'm gonna wait this one out i'm gonna
see this one out like you don't wanna be
the first one to get a tesla like brian
got one and he almost scratched on the
wall
some people have crashed in the walls
tesla now money
because it's like yeah they figured the
kinks out but also when people were like
i don't want to they just like hurried
up and came out with it i'm like
it's been a year yeah that's a lot like
i mean i don't know it's also the
smartest
minds in the world
out of the entire world the smartest
people of all time yeah well like
as a [ __ ] as a earth the smartest
people we have on earth were like we're
going to figure this out
and they all got together and we're like
we got to put a stop to this
i'm going to listen to them the people
plus there's a lot of pressure on them
yes
so it's like the more pressure they're
going to like and there's work and
there's money behind it and everyone's
like well they're just doing it to make
money
yeah i'm sure somebody's gonna make
money i don't give a [ __ ]
we have got to move forward man the
people that don't want to take it and
are saying they just hurried up
like they just hurried up and made it
they're thinking exactly that it's not
scientists that it's just like
the shamwow guy got together with
[ __ ] macaulay culkin
and they [ __ ] made it back it's like
no dude it's the best of the best
who sat down to figure this out i think
it's weird with like with like
charlemagne
i always listen to breakfast club he's
like yeah they want to give it to the
black and mexican communities first
why the [ __ ] we got to get a first link
because you're the most affected by it
so they want to give it to you guys
first
because you guys suffer the most from it
you have the most depth the news came
out they wanted
lebron james to take it live on
television oh really yeah
that doesn't make me feel better if let
me try because he's a [ __ ] it would
be great if he sat down like in
cleveland getting ready to do it and he
just goes i'm actually going to take
this video
i feel more comfortable doing this
seven vaccines oh man yeah you think
uh quick uh uh switch but do you think
he'll stick around long enough for his
son to play
yeah of course oh yeah i think how is
his son he's 20 he's 20 no he's 19 right
now oh yeah i'm sorry
i'm sorry eight seven does the nba 17
bro
my son number one chicago's like all
right yeah we'll take him number one
they'll make that work
right yeah he's gonna get a lot of team
long enough to make that story happen
for them that's insane
yeah right some veteran who's been
grinding
for 20 years like what i'm cut like yeah
i know dude
sorry little little lebron jersey he's
not even good we're like
no with asl i'm like man wait is he not
good i was born
lebron you have the resources he does
dude you have every tool you have the
physical capabilities to get to the nba
there's no reason you shouldn't be in
the nba yeah dude sean kemp told me
he was six seven as a freshman in high
school and when he
uh knew he was going to go pro he was in
he grew up in indiana
and he went to this camp and word i
guess travels fast when you're just
dope right oh yeah and obviously more so
now because video clips you know start
getting tossed around
yeah and uh his high school clips by the
way are
bonkers like i didn't really go back
yeah there's so many
sonic dunk highlights that you know you
don't really take time to go deep dive
like that but he was bonkers and
uh he said he got he was at this camp
and they brought in an indiana pacer to
play and he's like i'm not gonna say his
name because i don't embarrass him
and they had sean play him one-on-one
and he beat him 10-1 and dunked on him
twice
and after that his name went from sean
kemp to just straight nba
and he was like shortly after that he's
like i'm going pro just a little beast
yeah well did you ever hear when uh
jordan retired you know when he uh he
part owner i think of the was it
charlotte charlotte cats
they drafted that i think it's kwame
brown and jordan was like
on the fence about it it was kind of
soft and i guess during his like
second or third practice jordan went
down there played him one on one and
[ __ ] all over oh yeah they said just
ruined his mental psychologically [ __ ]
them up yeah oh that yeah for a fact
one of my thorn was like in a
three-piece suit was like you all right
dude
and just beat the [ __ ] at him that's a i
mean i guess
like trying to bully somebody like that
could maybe be good for their
development like if but like i don't
know dude if you got the goat coming at
you like that
yeah like you [ __ ] suck you piece of
[ __ ] yeah you're better than i never
loved you yeah
you're never gonna make it i don't know
why you're wearing my shoes
it uh talking to sean kemp is he like a
normal dude or normal man yeah it's
weird when you talk to guys that you
grew up loving and they're complete
narcissistic totally and you're all ah
this
is a you know i've only uh i think you
know we've all been around
enough cool [ __ ] and people at this
point do i think some of the star
struckness like definitely
fades away and you just know how to talk
to people like people right but
but yeah i definitely was geeking out on
the way there
because uh um because yeah like he was
in growing up there was just a handful
of things you know i wanted to [ __ ]
you know
do a spin move like camp i want to be on
double dare i want to [ __ ] go to
playboy mansion like these were just
childhood dreams
and uh and so talking to him live he was
our team
he was shut up
i would write letters to [ __ ] send to
wherever it was i think it was in
florida
and uh and i remember oh dude
win a [ __ ] bike get a trip to
disneyland definitely have a better shot
getting on double dare than you did
being like sean
campbell oh for sure also a small white
kid right yeah
so john kept like well you can do it
you definitely do it because i believe
in themselves living with a single mom
i'm like mom we got to go to disneyland
you can [ __ ] ask double dare to help
you out with that you know because uh
we're not gonna pay for that
and so i'd be writing these letters and
i remember i got to a point to where i
want to be on so bad and
right when my folk split and one of my
buddies was like dude you want to be on
double there so bad and he was like if
your parents like what would you rather
have
go on double dare or be contestant on
double dare or have your folks get back
together i was like dude i will take the
physical challenge i've already been
through the emotional challenge yeah i
want to [ __ ] go through the slime and
climb the [ __ ]
the nose and the uh also it just seemed
like such a
time yeah it was such a good time i'm
surprised mark summers was so coked up
i'm surprised they don't bring it back
who's the host i thought i thought they
tried
ex-comedian yeah they did bring it back
oh he used to host the comedy scene used
to do potluck we had him on the podcast
maybe four or five years ago and yeah he
used to he started off hosting
uh pollock at the store and then um kind
of like uh
he kind of was on like the bob saget
path where he's like a host for a while
and then
uh just got into that but yeah it's
tough when you get in where you get a
gig like that
and then it's you know bob saget's still
doing stand-up but he's you know he's
danny tanner yeah like that's what you
are dude
um but he was holding home he didn't fly
reboot did they bring oh that looks sad
oh new series 2018 2019 last season oh
it lasted a year yeah
damn the messiest game show on tv the
kids though were always so stupid like
that's what i loved about nickelodeon
game shows like nick arcade back in the
day did you ever watch that or
get the picture you guys were younger
than me but was that cable i didn't have
cable oh [ __ ] before my time was tough
did you have did you know what
nickelodeon was yeah i knew what it was
yeah from afar
this is i was like damn it did you watch
like uh keenan kell
yeah i just said i didn't have cable
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait no let me know you never saw any of
it
um well like at friends houses and [ __ ]
that's what i'm going to ask like yeah
i'm sure we all had somebody because i
had a i didn't have any game system up
until like probably end of high school
yeah let aloud so there's one kid named
brian hildebrand who not only had a
sports court and every gaming system had
[ __ ] arcade games
dude had the king-sized [ __ ] candy
bars from costco
you're like and he's like you can go buy
them too like yeah but you got but you
got
here they look fancier here it's like no
my mom just holds on to them longer
yeah um who's that kid for you um that
was
we we had this kid because we all skated
this dude had a half pipe in his
backyard
had a [ __ ] had a uh like studio set
up in his garage
like in his garage for like practice and
[ __ ] he was oh
this dude named what was his name orion
it sounded like i had to know ryan in
high school too never wore shoes
he was just a classic seattle hippie
never wore shoes teachers were like dude
put bug and he was like nah man he's
like you put shoes on
all right that's not really how i was
teaching you're like all right
you
at some point about guys that just like
that they just wake up
like just with their hair messy and like
smell weird but look so hot and there's
like
i'm ready for the free [ __ ] or whatever
i'm butchering it but it was so funny
but this kid was exactly
like he just had that he just looked
cool no shoes and girls were just like
he like doesn't need shoes like he's one
of those guys that like his feet are
like kind of like
they're strong enough to like withstand
like the concrete yeah like
what are you just talking about those
[ __ ] in love with them about
that free spirit
totally yeah absolutely yeah just didn't
care too they'd be like hi orion he's
like [ __ ] off
oh he's walking into that forest well
anyway when he comes back out
i hope he looks at me because he was
just like all over the place hi
all the time definitely hopefully he's
killed
yeah yeah hopefully he's killing it
though as an adult he's always that old
ryan you had an orion
we did it man that [ __ ] wouldn't fly in
aurora colorado it was all about
sneakers
and jerseys oh so
so you'd either stand out or you'd get
what just [ __ ] on and people would
no it was kind of like it was like jocks
were like
the thing and it was like there was that
and like fashion was big
i don't know it was like you know that
was the thing so if there was a kid with
no shoes on here we got clown
soap oh my god i would have killed him
especially at the back of the school bus
would have just made him cry oh yeah so
it was just like yeah dude bus drivers
don't or maybe they do realize how much
[ __ ] is going on in the back of the bus
oh they do they don't know nowadays it's
probably just finger city you know what
i'm saying
guys and girls are swapping juices yeah
but i remember my bus drive in louisiana
he'll
run through red lights like an uber
driver trying to get you to the airport
because he was late he was like y'all
hold on we'll have a seat
i swear to god i would like it if the
bus driver took a little
accountability like dude was never
saying buckle up yeah
yeah no one's ever buckled up my sister
you know how dangerous buses are
you're on a bench that's it that's it
there's no
yeah yeah there's nothing if you get a
wreck you're flying the other bench
oh yeah but you're just [ __ ] around
yeah like i hope that but i would
love if a bus driver took some
accountability like hey let's not
fight back here let's not beat up that
one
kid hey let's not jump timmy in the back
like nothing you always see you always
see him look in the rearview mirror and
just be like you're getting paid enough
there was this kid named dwight angle
and there was a top of a hill uh that we
would pick him up at called
uh it was called killer hill because the
hill was so steep and some kid went down
on it uh
on his skateboard or bike and just got
slammed by a truck it was basically like
you go all the way down the hill and
then at the bottom of the hill was like
a four-way stop and then you go up
another hill
so he just tried to go straight through
and caught somebody that just was like
you know probably that bus driver that
just ran the red
did he die oh yeah and so that's what he
called a killer hill oh otherwise would
have been a close call hill
yeah but uh close call yeah but so so we
would come around that corner to
to get dwight and dwight was always late
and the bus driver
would always knew he was late and just
was had such a thing of like i'm not
stopping for anybody like we i know i
have to get to school by this time
and so eight out of ten times to what we
would
pass the thing and just as the bus would
start to kind of pick up momentum and
start to roll down the hill
dwight and you'd see him come running
around the corner and
like if a kid's named dwight angle yeah
his run is gonna be
the goofiest run [ __ ] rat
dude i mean dwight's the best i mean he
dude he ran for president high school
and
instead of signing the slip that says i
like all the things you abide by instead
of signing
dwight angle he put don't agree because
he was so against the system
yeah and i love it but like but him and
i were trying to run together like vp
and prez and so we have this whole thing
and so
and so he writes don't agree and they
look at it and they go do i does this
say don't agree he's like yeah
and they're like you can't run he's like
all right god damn it dude
the whole campaign so he's running
behind the bus
just flying and we're all like looking
and it was like so sad but
so like out of a disney movie just so
funny because at one point he's running
and sprinting a kid in the fifth grade
full-on trying to catch the bus like
that depends on it and then at one point
just drops his bag
and dropped his coat and just now he's
just trying to catch the bus
being like i'll get new books and a new
coat later
yeah dude and just the bus drive kept
going and he did catch it one time that
was your vp
huh
so i ran unopposed and so i didn't even
have to give a uh
did you win yeah oh yeah you were class
probably i was running against vice
president
for high school and so basically i did
because i want to run the
the vice president really didn't do much
but they ran the assemblies and did a
lot so it was like the performing one
and i got and i just
was like i'm gonna make [ __ ] fun and
funny and yeah your pep rallies was lit
they're pretty cool yeah
i bet they were like a lot of sketches
and [ __ ] like that but our president was
this kid uh he played the football team
his name was jeremiah fulford foster
what do you think that guy looks like
wow jet jeremiah fulford foster football
player
oh yeah worked at uh hollywood video
which was like the uh it was the
blockbuster yeah and i would go down
there and uh
and i remember i had rented mlb 2001 for
playstation
and just played it every night and i
remember i rented it in uh
beginning of the year and it's like now
end of the year and i kind of come down
there one
one high school night and he's like hey
adam um and he was a real
sweet guy but a little passive so like
as a president he was a little like even
in our speeches
i'd bust his balls and like whatever and
and he was like
can you stop making me look like a
[ __ ] [ __ ] in front of the whole
school like dude
because he couldn't like bang her back
and so um
uh and uh except from one student
council thing he just
did tell me he was just like he couldn't
think of anything to say and i was like
well well like jerry and he was just
like
[ __ ] you man everybody started laughing
because he never heard that
but so uh he's like man you've had a
he's like it says you've had mlb 2001
for almost a year he's like he's like
there's just thousands of dollars of
late fees and he's like you got to bring
it back man he's like i'll let the
wait i'll wave the late fees he's like
but you got to bring it back and i go
that's not going to happen oh that game
is so fun man
i'm keeping this one he goes please man
you got to bring it back he goes i'm
leaving in a week i gotta like i i got
to get everything wiped off the sleigh i
was like
it's so fun man have you played it he's
like no man is it
why is it great i was like yeah i'm not
bringing it back he's like please i go
no he goes
all right just such a pushover
i remember going to blockbuster and my
we'd always return the movies late and
my mom would always talk her way out of
paying the fee she's like
just give us this one time the next time
you had that mom and they would always
let us go yeah i said hey blockbuster
all the great movies were renting out
that was the worst all the time
i just go hey anyway turn in and i'd be
like you know cyborg
oh yeah or that'll be the best when
someone walks right in you're looking
for one and they drop it off
she's like oh we did you have land
before time 10 it's right there
i bought it that reference
yeah yeah triceratops yeah dude the
story's got a little whacked by the end
though it was like yeah i was like hey
can ducky deep throw the shrimp and it
was like
stories they're running out of ideas
but those got knocked off when the
netflix came around and stuff
no this is hollywood
what was the email was it like a covet
type thing like we're all in this
together red box
keep fighting for what's right dairy
queen
it was strange the holocaust was a hoax
my pillow yeah i agreed to disagree my
pal oh yeah
no the email was i think i showed it to
you it was long it was like
hey man we're all fans of fighting the
kids at redbox
let you know we're flourishing we have
this many thousand red box open
you know we are launching specials on
there so when you want to launch your
special let us know
hey bubba i'm not launching a special
with a red box
dude the problem is i mean that's cut
wait so
did they were great though he's super
nice first of all that is just dope are
they in cahoots with 7-eleven or is that
just
i don't know what they're always no yes
and walgreens right what are those
amazon ones
i see those amazon the locker the lock
yeah what is that that's i don't think
there's nothing to do with videos okay
why don't you talk about them you gotta
be careful if you make fun of redbox
though because like cabbage they'll give
you an email we're flourishing
what do they offer do they give you like
a deal breakdown like they're just
what if they just have so many well they
do and there's like thousands and like
we're getting the streaming game and
we're doing this they're just
overcompensating like we want to shoot a
50 million dollar special for you yeah
like you're hardcore
i don't i don't want to do that but
there are going to be more platforms
like that they're going to take chances
right i mean i'm still surprised apple
hasn't really
[ __ ] with it but uh they are at some
point i really offered chappelle a
ton of money at some point to be the
like guinea pig for it apple yeah
i tell you what's going to be
interesting because in the podcast space
when you think about apple and podcast
right apple
has the best by far like interface and
like app for for
podcasting you know apple podcasting but
now that spotify is doing their
subscription
platform stuff like that at some point
you got a apple seem like hey man
we like money yeah you guys use all this
[ __ ] for free
we have all this networking going on
it's going to start costing money for
people to listen to the podcast
that's going to come yeah it's dope here
it's not done
it's not for money for to put it if
you're [ __ ] up no no
how much money do they need so now this
is free if you want to listen to fighter
and the kid
or king this thing or below the belt
food truck app all you gotta do is go to
apple download it
you get it for free if you have an apple
uh phone eventually apple's gonna go hey
we're in the money game too now you
gotta pay for this service yeah
that's not cool so you wouldn't you're
you're gonna because what's gonna happen
because
imagine if youtube did that yeah it was
like hey youtube ain't free anymore
now to watch any video it's 9.99 a month
yeah so the audience isn't going
it's going to shrink but also youtube is
like okay we need money so let's get
youtube tv
so if you want to buy anything or watch
any stream or any tv show
ten dollars a month or just like you'll
pay for that right
you'll pay for that like for youtube but
what it does is as
as you're a podcaster yeah so what it's
going to do is
narrow your fan base if youtube shuts
down
that is an opening for you porn to be
like hey all those silly cat videos we
got them now
yeah we also got bukkakee videos but
someone launched something with a porn
network who
i think didn't mark norman might even
been on this show say that clips of his
were on the site somebody said that
their [ __ ] got uploaded
funny someone said someone launched one
with them
wow can you imagine that agent
netflix netflix comedy central
no hear me out here man that one's
saying you porn no it's just
it's like probably like you know like
parodies but you're gonna be the first
yeah dude dude just think about it
there's only two anal ads right before
your
special so though the deal is you gotta
promote the new [ __ ]
video
do you have any latino stepmom jokes
because that is going to they compare
that they get 500 million views a month
if we just get a fraction yeah
but that's got to be a lot and then all
of a sudden you're like that makes a lot
of sense
yeah yeah you're getting awesome i'm
like but they're coming with a jack off
man you have to watch
comments yeah i know it's like if i
walked into a [ __ ] and started doing
my routine yeah
like that's pretty much everyone's like
what what the [ __ ]
how many of those eyeballs what kind of
degenerates going to pour them like
i could use a little comedy right now or
just finished
finishes coming and they're just like
who's the who's the new comic guy yeah
how weird is that someone did that damn
you couldn't find it chin
no no so i i forget what who did it you
sure it's a porn site or is it i'm
positive
someone someone knows something someone
launched they're special
either they're special or like a fight
clip a clip a clip like one of you have
one of those clips
someone had yeah you know they started
fights on pornhub as well though
they had like the how do you know this
crowner versus mcgregor
uh mayweather fight how are you even
born up huh how are you i don't want
part of that
here's here's where it gets interesting
if you listen to dana white lately they
have this big
push to come after illegal streamers and
dana
they they go through because people talk
[ __ ] they're like oh i'm still gonna do
i'm still gonna do it
and they found a guy and they're gonna
prosecute him
and you're looking at 20 you're making
it you're getting two years so they'll
make an example
some poor dude probably live in a
trailer park he's been streaming god
knows what
and he's like what the [ __ ] dana's like
yeah we're following him we got his
phone records
he goes i'm telling you man if you
illegally stream this we're gonna
prosecute you to the fullest extent
you're looking at 20 years
so they think that's going to push
people off do you stupid way you know
you know what y'all was gonna say do you
how do you feel about that
i pay for it right yeah but um you're
you're never gonna stop these guys it's
always gonna be a problem this is always
gonna be a fight
so it's always gonna be fun so if you a
guy i'm telling you you don't want to be
part of it
yeah that's awesome you don't want to be
in prison for legally streaming for 20
years you don't because you'll be
holding guys like me you're gonna be
holding their pocket
in the yard yeah by the way how many uh
more
uh athletes need to come out of the
woodwork to to fight to where
uh you go oh i'm i wouldn't turn down
some of this money to do it
what do you mean how much money would it
take for if they said for me personally
yeah to jump back in
ah i don't know have you thought about
that no yeah
yeah i thought you came up with a
problem right i said the rock yeah yeah
you said you
have to be like a major star you'd fight
the rock yeah i'd fight the right you're
not allowed right yeah
oh oh yeah that's true i send voice
notes yeah oh
he sent me a bunch of tequila when i got
engaged whatever he did oh
she told me everything was going well
nah
he's like she came over with some
tequila i thought that was cool
that was the rocks dream yeah man we uh
yeah we it's funny we
uh so you know it all really started
when um
uh it was just like about a year ago a
couple weeks ago when gwyneth paltrow
came out with that vagina candle right
yep and uh and i saw it and i it just
said that
they sold out you know they were 75
bucks a piece for a candle smells like a
vagina
sold out and i was like this is crazy i
was like there's no dude equipment so i
posted a picture of it
and i was like who would be the guy that
would be like the male equivalent to
sell like a ball candle right
and so and i never tagged people like
that just because whatever
i was [ __ ] up one time in new york and
uh i saw katy perry was
leaving a broadway show and i was about
to do shows at gotham and i just [ __ ]
sent her a dm or
she come to the late show and uh and i
was like why did i do that and uh did
she come
no okay no of course not but but just
you might have they would
be regular people exactly and the
accessibility of having that i was just
like oh whatever
and uh and uh and so i tagged the rock
and then he commented on it i started
getting all these dms being like oh how
do you know the rock and i was like
everybody knows a rock what the [ __ ] are
you talking about yeah and i looked at
the at the post and he had commented on
it and then it got picked up by all
these
you know sites or whatever and then and
then he followed me and then uh
sent him a message and then sent me a
message back and coming back and forth
and then uh
got an audition for his his show and uh
and uh last yeah what's the show called
young rock it's about oh yeah yeah
on nbc february 16th and um
what do you play in it i can't say who i
play but um because it's
oh you can't oh yeah yeah i signed the
whole thing but um
but it's a dude and it's uh played dude
yeah it's awesome i went to australia
for uh six weeks and
quarantined for two weeks and then took
the mask off and did stand up every
night and went to rugby games
jet skiing and [ __ ] shot the show was
awesome and how was the rock when you
met him in person so we've only met over
zoom just
just to be clear voice notes i like the
rock it's not that i want to fight the
rock because i don't
know because it'd be a great show i know
because i want to make bank bro
oh yeah so if rock was actually like
who said that like he used to be a
former fighter he's like i'll fight
schaub
yeah and then you have the rocks fan
base and then we're both making 100 mil
where the [ __ ] it is yeah
i'm into that yeah i'm not doing it
because i dislike i appreciate the rock
when he represents too yeah
he's talking about a name he's the most
likeable guy i think he got bored of the
most likable
nobody's
even my mom's like i kind of like the
rock you know what i'm saying like it's
he's got something for everybody
yeah yeah now he's got an energy drink
but yeah we uh
it's so funny too because we'll you know
there'll be times when it's like back
and forth for a week and then there'll
be like a month in between
and then he'll send like a five minute
voice note just recapping everything
we miss and then we'll talk about
whatever and we've talked on the phone
four or five times and um when he told
me he got the
i got the job i was i went to
chappelle's camp in ohio this summer for
a weekend
and uh and i was uh taking a [ __ ] and i
get a call from him and i'm just like
and he's like give me your best
blah blah blah the guys uh who i'm
playing and uh and i do the
do the voice and then uh and he's like
you got the job and then we just talked
for like an hour and a half
about everything dude was it it's crazy
inspirational dude he was i mean
when we were just it was like almost i
mean it's the way we're joking around is
how he is
at one point he's we're talking about
the xfl and he's like man that place is
it was just a it was a just a [ __ ] barn
and i go up
and uh and i go you took that over yeah
and i go dude if we don't open a
frozen yogurt late night store called
[ __ ] barn you and i are both a
disappointment to our families yeah and
then he's like no [ __ ] barnes got to be
late night pizza and then we started
like joking about all this [ __ ]
and uh and you know him being um uh you
know his his journey into wrestling
which is what the show is about
because his dad was a big wrestler he
kind of had the paulie around the comic
experience where he was around all these
[ __ ]
things yeah yeah and so the show takes
you through uh
you know uh up until this first season i
think it's just up until his uh college
years and then
and then post that my uh character
is very instrumental in his wrestling
course that's cool man good for you
brother yeah
how was chappelle's camp in ohio yeah
and did you you performed at that i
didn't
perform that weekend i was going to but
then uh john mayer came through
it was like the most stacked weekend
they'd had and it was just like
they always had michelle wolf donnell
and mo ammer and um
and uh and then tiffany came and then
louis came and sarah came
and so uh my boy who's um uh dave's tour
manager was like
he's like dude he's like it's now six or
seven people before dave he's like i
just can't too much
and i was like oh good here for the hang
julia white's uh uh
good butt of mine and we went out
together is he really yeah oh my god oh
yeah bro
i'm a massive fan of jalil well calm
right now oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] are you serious yeah dude i i've
been
running back family matters like it's my
favorite show
of all time are you serious yeah so to
become friends yeah dude
dude we just came real good friends adam
yeah
uh i mean now he's doing this uh i mean
still acts a lot shows a lot of public
appearance stuff yeah
um he was hosting his [ __ ] showing
sci-fi for a little bit
but he'll pop up in shows and now he's
doing a show on instagram live uh with
his daughter
yeah look at that calm real quick he's
great i love him he's a man and we
connect i mean we've gone to basketball
games he comes to all my shows he's been
to the store
so many times i mean the backboard
drinking so we went out to the chappelle
camp and uh
and he knows dave from back in the day
so it was a great ann and tiff and
everybody and
and we got real high the opening like
moment there we go it was like the
thursday for the weekend right and there
were shows and it was just another
every weekend a new crop of people were
coming through and we're in this little
restaurant in the back area and i just
get a little too high i'm a little too
on cloud nine
and uh and dave starts uh giving a
little speech right and everybody gets
everybody's attention
all right this is another great weekend
everybody's gonna be great everybody
enjoy yourselves
and i'm just way too high to be there
and like i should have read the room
like i said
what up to dave and he [ __ ] i was
like you probably don't remember me but
we've been into the store a lot and he's
like no no i'm good and
just so nice and over the weekend dude
so attentive when he found out i got the
job uh
cena his tour manager told him he came
up gave me a big hug was like that's
huge for you
[ __ ] we it was just so nice the whole
time and uh and was i come back at any
time
all this [ __ ] yeah because we had a nice
away from the clubs away from the you
know
at his house at the in the farm in these
areas where it was like eight of us just
shooting the [ __ ]
and he's just so he's the goat offstage
too man because he makes you feel
uh important and he's like even if you
ask a question and he's got to get up
and go somewhere
you know uh he stops says something
maybe opens it up to the group
and then walks away and move it huh yeah
yeah
nice way to bring the energy down i'm
like dude
he's not going to die no but he got coed
if anybody's going to be fine it's me
chappelle he got coveted so him and
rogan are supposed to do shows
i think tonight and tomorrow and those
are canceled yeah now i wonder if elon
got it
i don't know that is the question
definitely crazy you tested positive a
couple times remember oh yeah
yeah yeah elon that's a false positive
though
i mean if you do it twice it's kind of
like what the hell how do you know yeah
i feel like a guy like that probably
already had the vaccine too right elon
yeah
um but uh but yeah it was great but so
so we're this and dave's given the
speech and i'm just too high and there
was like a standing bucket of ice you
know those like ice buckets are just
kind of raised up for you to
be at that dream usually silver i just
[ __ ] i thought it was just like
stuck to the ground so it's again a room
maybe twice the size of this dave's
giving this speech
and in the pause between he's about to
say something so it's dead quiet
i lean on this ice bucket and it just
slides and i just go
yeah it goes straight down hit the
ground ice goes everywhere
the seas just part everyone looks at me
and dave just sticks his head on and
goes whoop new guy
like i always want my wits about me you
know me too dude but i was why'd you do
so high
it was around also it was just like also
it was just like
you know smoke with jay and then smoke
with dave
you know in a circle so i wasn't gonna
get it wasn't dave pass me and i wasn't
gonna be like yeah i'm too [ __ ] up man
i don't wanna knock over some ice i just
take it
i can hit it uh tiff you know common was
light and incense i don't think he
smokes her drinks
he just had incense or whatever there's
another uh the uh state station
sage dude this was the coolest [ __ ] ever
and i was so baked and he was so cool
because like
he just would take out a piece of wood
me him and jaleel just chatting and he
just takes out a little piece of sage
and just lights it and just starts going
like this and i just making watching
mid conversation just i don't know he's
just always trying to get rid of the
demons or something i don't know and
that's what i mean
and i've never seen that before what are
you
talking about hold on i don't know what
you should do i don't want any more ice
getting knocked over yeah
i tried to i just started laughing i was
like what the [ __ ] are you doing because
i was like oh stage brother i was like
i'm like no i know what it is
no i definitely why do you keep doing
that every room
they feel like to me it's the same thing
where and i was saying this i was like
it's also like if you light up a
cigarette and just start blowing like
you almost
when a courtesy ask like hey is it cool
if i just put a new smell
around everybody but no he just was like
and just [ __ ]
and then you just you know and yeah yeah
yeah that's just range
yeah that's just that how does
confidence how does no one go hey dude
what quit doing that yeah i don't know i
don't give a
[ __ ] but yeah what does sage do
[Music]
it's just like the energy thing it's
like [ __ ] energy thing yeah like
like negative ions but everyone there's
good moods you know it's so it's like
what
what's going on here man what the demons
do you have
we're gonna do this every room did you
see kyrie every before the game he had
just like go around the td garden
another weird person what was the guy on
uh what was that movie with charlie
sheen
baseball oh major league major league
what did the uh african dude do he had
the little he had saved
and then one of the pitchers came over
and like pissed on it he was like [ __ ]
what are you doing he's like [ __ ] you
you cake he's like you can't say that
man
[ __ ] you he just pisses all over it
that's right
yeah oh man that's crazy uh but yeah it
was bonkers man and john mayer i mean
there was
seeing them together is uh i've seen
their show
uh it's i think it's called like
controlled dangers yeah and uh
john's out there serenading everybody
and we're sitting back in the green room
and dave's just watching
and uh and then and just killing all the
girls who are watching just with you
know open mouths and wide eyes and dave
just goes looks up and he goes
[ __ ] jokes don't fail me now because
it's like how am i supposed to follow
this yeah yeah yeah
but uh but boys are killing it during
the quarantine
hell yeah the whole gabe was just like
yeah i'm just gonna do my own
[ __ ] oh yeah yeah they filmed the whole
documentary about it um because i
uh when i was in nazi a couple weeks ago
and and popped in and saw donnelly i was
like so what were all those
cameras because they were just filming
everything and i assumed it was for
something but you know sometimes they're
just there's always guys like that
you're just filming everything to kind
of have it for whatever but they were uh
definitely doing they're doing a dock i
guess it's coming out in the spring on
the whole
summer oh never because i mean it was
crazy man i mean they were yeah they
were
crazy abby the people that were coming
through
you know adam ray you know it's crazy
i'm joking um louie chris
does come out like that but there's just
one shot of me with common like what the
[ __ ] is that it's you
pushing over the eyes
if they have the shot oh yeah yeah they
they freeze like adam right
without
[Laughter]
yeah it's funny because uh people are
giving comics
trust me i know this we're giving comic
[ __ ] for doing shows
during covid and then i remember rogan
asked chappelle like hey
do you ever worry about like comments
like doing shows he goes
i don't give a [ __ ] yeah you know it's
the same thing it's like the public
decides whether you can do shows or not
yeah
if it's a safe environment and they want
to come out and you know they're willing
to take the risk if there is a risk you
know with that stuff
it's on them man the public let you know
if you can do shows yeah
yeah yeah the ones who dictate it they
set it up i mean they had a big that
outdoor pavilion was uh and they tested
every i mean it was a really
safe operation man um you know and they
just they create a bubble you know which
is i think the way
anyone is going about trying to see
people and be safe about it
yeah um it's just uh you know make sure
you're good before you get in there
get clear on the test and then if
everyone's good and i mean
that's how i don't understand how
they're you know succeeding with
basketball
so swiftly because it's like those guys
get to go home right they're not i mean
they're traveling no
they well they can go home but they they
can't go like to parties and see other
people
if they go somewhere else but they they
have to notify the team
but they can't but are they booted up
like how are they it's the honor system
right yeah well yeah but you're [ __ ]
man you missed games or you bring kobit
back to the team it's fine now
it's kind of like you know and it's a
big it's uh like what did you think i'm
gonna get i don't want to rehash things
but uh well kyrie but like with uh the
dodgers with um
oh what's his face [ __ ] taking the
mask off captain just celebrating
the [ __ ] uh uh evan turner
evan turner or jason what's up zero
problem kevin turner i think he's i
think
no [ __ ] something turner he had a
register you might be right it's jason
turner
isn't it right it's jason turner you
have the red beard yeah
right is this guy no no it's that third
one that's justin turner
yeah yeah um didn't give you what
happened so he got he found out he had
covered in like the
i don't know fifth or seventh yeah went
back out celebrated
uh you know hugged everybody like had
his mask on i think sometimes but
then took it off for the pictures yeah
but everybody was and i mean dude i
don't know i was definitely like i don't
i don't know what that move is because
like
man you finally get one and you are part
all the teams that i'm celebrating
yeah like but but also you just got it
like i don't know maybe
you got you just got it but there's a
ton of false positive tests
also you just got it and then everyone
around you is healthy in shape so it's
kind of i would just do this i would run
away from it and they're like you're
positive like well i gotta go i can't
hear you yeah can't hear you and like
they probably also ask them like wait
till everyone gets off the field and go
out there by yourself [ __ ] that like
what is that about here no and dude so
he knew right there when he was holding
up
how was he like did he like have like
crazy symptoms like after that or
anything nope
he was fine yep was everyone else fine
yep
yes yeah it's like at that point what
can you do
uh when he was out there with chappelle
yeah they had like a softball
like kind of thing oh yeah like
dodgeball stuff yeah none of that was
that uh that weekend it was more just
[ __ ] it's like a big karaoke party
isn't it just yeah just i mean
i mean just partying nonstop i mean he
had this little like
like barn that we would go back to after
the shows and just uh
5 6 a.m and then next day getting those
uh iv drips which i know you love
yeah i love them too dude i would always
see those and be like i gotta like
figure that out it was my my first time
doing it but in a long time
yeah it felt great great totally good i
was like comment i get the i get the
[ __ ] stage thing now like i felt
like saging you've got a bunch of sage
no but it was like i mean yeah it was uh
immediate
you know yeah immediate you feel better
yeah and they just had uh were you
boozing too down there
yeah yeah i try to you know i think i
i i went through stages of like smoking
more during this pandemic like at night
like i'm not a real big smoke during the
day
guy i never have been why do you have
[ __ ] to do yeah
and i just i don't know i just i'm not
it's a it's not a wrap for me like i can
definitely have a couple puffs and
and i've definitely been getting high on
stage no yeah
i probably have like six times in 15
years you know and
two of those times unbelievable like
didn't
question you know because i like to you
know whether it's doing crowd work in my
act or whatever i just want to have all
my
uh weapons at my disposal you know and
it's like i i don't want to feel like i
can't
and what what stopped it really was and
even for drinking it's like i'll take a
drink up there to have a sip for
whatever
uh and maybe on a late show if it's
really rowdy i'll take a couple more
sips just to kind of like
you know um uh you know get on the level
with the with the room but uh
i just don't like not being in control
and able to handle anything because
there's been a few times where
i was maybe you know those few times i
smoked or were a little too uh sauced up
to where something happened
and i still was able to get through
whatever it was but i wasn't like it's
funny
i didn't crush the moment like i know i
couldn't i was like [ __ ] that like it's
uh
um and also you so you're more of a wind
down kind of
smoker then yeah yeah i mean but it's
like also it's been funny if you were
that high
out of control high when you tipped over
the ice thing and they're like all right
adam
we're going to give you seven wait
oh yeah you're up bubba it did sober
you're following
louis ck there we heard you're really
funny though
oh dude trust me a lot of uh that
doesn't mean you're up
cause i cuz i got up by the way and just
go i go i go sorry i go sorry about the
ass i go dave
back to you so uh but if he had stopped
and been like
who are you and like what's going on but
he just went right back into his [ __ ]
yeah
thank god but um but yeah i mean um i've
gotten high
one i got high once when i just said i
you know i'm not a big smoker
at high with rogan and sam tripoli yeah
like i hit this i'm telling you i'm
asking me better up there
and it was one of the one times adam
egypt from the comedy store was watching
my set no
and i ate all the dicks yeah i forgot
where i was at my set
well you're just perfect and if you saw
him oh i was fine but then
then but no i like when i was [ __ ] up
and [ __ ] up my bit
then i saw him standing like oh no and
then you're in your head yeah i've never
smoked since
wow never so are you even open to
you know opportunities like if you find
yourself like let's say you're in austin
elon musk rogan
dave no they got blood no no snoop nope
wow i'm just i'm just i don't have my
wits about
i'm not as sharp when i'm high i'm not
i'm not a
experienced smoker right so it's like if
especially i'm gonna hang with
not elon he's not yeah he's one of those
funnier [ __ ] zone
yeah but if it's dave and rogan and like
you know these mon
[ __ ] these monsters yeah yeah i want
to be maybe yeah what about when your uh
boy grows up to uh be uh what's your
son's name again tiger tiger
such a dope name thanks man uh nicknames
for it
tt nice teeters teeters yeah big t
yeah if he gets to the age and he starts
to dabble and he's like yo pops
like i know you won't do it with the big
dogs but
it's [ __ ] teeter's here
and it says like best dad in the world
on the blunt
i might have to try yeah yeah you might
have to
tell me how my dad kept me away from
drugs like i didn't drink or smoke till
i got into stand-up
never never dude because sports and
being successful in college
were always distractions my dad used to
tell me when i was young
because my favorite my favorite was adam
sandler jim carrey and junior sale those
were my heroes
awesome i love junior sale and adam
sandler my dad was like they don't smoke
or drink
if you want to be like them you want to
get there you're not going to if you do
this you're never going to get there
so i was like okay i'm just not going to
do it all it takes that's all i was like
oh i'm not going to do it
little did i know do you think he's like
he's like yo your favorite
jim belushi he doesn't drink he doesn't
smoke but you don't i was like oh yeah
he's right
literally i know he had a [ __ ] heroin
problem he was drinking every night wait
jim belushi or john belushi which one
died
you said jim john yeah yeah yeah yeah
i'm sure jim did you know
the famed sitcom according to jim which
was my first tv job oh really
it's on my youtube channel you can put
the clip shin i sent you the clip
and go check it uh
yeah okay
this would be my from the season
premiere because it was a season
premiere you know from according to gym
remember going to a host of the improv
once and he goes so what do you want me
to say i go uh you can see me on the
season premiere of according to jim and
he goes
what the [ __ ] is that and i go oh it's a
show with jim
you just say you can say he loves comedy
oh it was like the water boy that uh
that he went back
he was a water boy yeah i had three
scenes you know and all right
i dropped these [ __ ] jugs what year
is this oh 2007
life is full of circles that's funny
every time jim
they fake sexy notes to the wife and say
it's from me to make her feel good
[Laughter]
i don't know if you could do this series
in 2021 right here can you do this
water delivery how are you right here
adam this was uh
2007. by the way for sure the most
according to the gym you've ever watched
on this show
like doesn't make it so quiet i was like
this is great
terrible but uh uh yeah i remember i
walked up to his trailer at the end of
that
it was the legend it was the first tv
job you know uh
that i uh had which is why i was just
you know like telling when i would go up
on stage be like [ __ ] going to gym
you got you know you're looking for a
credit right
and um even if they misspelled if you
know if they were somebody that looked
like you
on a show you were like you know like
you used that credit i was on jimmy
kimmel i was like
i just kind of looked like you i was
[ __ ] just say it man yeah yeah and uh
and so uh i go
um i'm pulling up to the lot and uh
henry winkler uh
his son max was my fraternity at usc so
i got to know henry became almost like a
little bit of a mentor right the fonz
and so
i'd call him every couple months for
advice on business whatever was so nice
um when i first met him he walked into
my fraternity and he uh had a bag of
clothes and it was like parents weekend
and there's like
nobody around and uh he just walks in
and i'm just like holy [ __ ] he walks up
he goes hello uh excuse me because do
you live here and i go
uh yeah i go uh what's up he goes henry
winkler i go i [ __ ] know he goes of
course you do
and i go i go what's going on he goes i
have egos you know my son max i go
everybody loves him max is the yeah he's
the grace he goes i have his laundry
would you make sure it gets to him
safely i go you got it man i [ __ ] got
it he's about to hand to me and he pulls
it back he goes hold on a second he goes
you're not gonna do anything weird with
his clothes are you i go what do you
mean he goes you're not gonna [ __ ] on
him or something like that
what he goes it's a fraternity he goes
you're not going to do some sort of like
weird [ __ ] i know you guys like do
[ __ ] weird stuff here
i go henry winkler you have my uh
promise scout's honor
no defecating poop diary nothing's gonna
end up on max's pants
and he's like i love that no [ __ ] on the
clothes i go no [ __ ] on the clothes
hands them to me and then we start
talking about
tell them i'm an actor all this stuff
and then uh and then down the line
i pulled into the lot for according to
jim and i'm like i should call henry get
some sitcom advice he was the [ __ ]
king
and uh and so i'm pulling up to the lot
and this is a time by the way when i was
driving this like
beat up ford escape that i had like
bungee cords holding on the bumper
windows that have been smashed at duct
tape bottom i was just like i'm gonna
ride this thing to i remember pulling
into the store of this thing
and everyone's got all these nice cars
and people are just like when are you
gonna get a [ __ ] new car
yeah and some guys even bobby was like
hey according to jim you can't afford to
get these you know bungee cables
upgraded and so i pointed a lot and i
had like a fat suit back there and a
couple puppets
and like all this [ __ ] for like these
youtube videos i was doing and i pulled
up and i'm so nervous and i'm in the
and so the security guard's going
through my [ __ ] real heavyset sassy
black lady and she's just so fun and
i've seen her a couple times for dress
rehearsals
and i pull up and she's like mr ray how
you doing i was like good i'm just a
little nervous first
tv job ever and she's going through my
[ __ ] and she pulls up the fat suit and
the puppet
and there was i think there was even
like a fake like dildo we used for this
brett favre
um [ __ ] it was like it was a wrangler
it was a wrangler jeans sketch that was
like uh
spoofing the wrangle jeans commercial
but it was far about throwing footballs
with his buddies
it's on youtube and he uh but it was we
had like this fake [ __ ] that he had that
he would always pull out and just hit
everybody in the face in slo-mo
with like the wrangler jeans right
behind it and so uh that was back there
and i'm literally looking in the
rearview mirror and she holds up the
puppet the fat suit and the fake [ __ ]
and she goes what the [ __ ] is this
and i was like oh i just it's for some
sketches she's like let me guess you
single and i was like yes i am [ __ ] i'm
really nervous trying to get to my first
i'm hanging out with jim belushi today
and so she drops all that and i go in
and and uh and then henry left me this
voicemail that was like
you know treat mr blushy like an emperor
like if you think of something funny
say it don't just be there to fill space
he was like they picked adam ray for a
reason they want adam ray they love adam
right
they need adam right yeah all the best
oh wow wish i saved it
so cut two were doing something yeah
yeah you're doing the live taping
right and you know sitcoms are just
moving if they do a joke and it doesn't
hit
everybody uh you know commiserates and
they try to come up whatever so i'm
leaning over i'm staying over there we
did this scene
uh one of the last ones one of these
jokes didn't hit so everybody gets
together
writers producers belushi courtney
thornsmith and uh
and i think of a joke to say and i hear
henry in my head being like if you think
it's something funny say it
so i lean over and i just like find this
moment i go oh i could say you could say
that
and then they all just kind of turned
and looked at me
and uh turned back to like the writers
and then i just hear henry in my head go
swinging a miss and then i told him
after i go henry i go i took your advice
i pitched a joke and they all looked at
me like i was [ __ ]
like a [ __ ] idiot and he's like well
it has to be funny
but uh but that guy's that guy's the
goat man he is legend um dude you're
still friends with his son now
yeah yeah he's a you know director and
um he's doing a bunch of cool [ __ ] but
um
yeah i mean henry's like the [ __ ] i mean
he's just like
regarded as like the nicest guy and it's
you it makes sense when you see how many
shows he continues to pop up on right
like
yeah crashes yeah still crushing what's
that one uh barry
yeah that's right yeah yeah that's right
a good one yeah he was the actor it's
his last big one
yeah um hbo right
what berries on hbo yeah is it yeah yeah
so that was aggressive you don't have
cables so how would you know yeah i know
i don't have it
okay well let me take a piss jen what's
up cat what's up
gotcha food all right man uh well the
hallelum raise is here cat just came
with hound race for chappelle's birthday
his birthday's tomorrow
oh [ __ ] dude did you get the hot
sandwich of course we're gonna eat it on
there that [ __ ]
is fire good uh how are you feeling for
the birthday
i feel good i'm 34. yeah yeah you look
good yeah how old are you thirty-eight
yeah yeah i'll be 38 in march for real
dude look at that thirty-eight brothers
thirty bucks
oh yeah yeah yeah you didn't boy i was i
was gonna say like 36.
he's like 38 wow i wouldn't pick shot
what do you think i don't know 37.
give me two years yeah i was looking for
like a 32 30.
like 28. well you said you did that in
2007. oh yeah yeah yeah i think like 37
yeah i'll give you all right two years
on that note some things you can just
think and not
say adam you're a
working man you got to get out of here
brother yeah dude we got to cut you out
of here well thanks for having me
yeah thanks for coming on the show [ __ ]
i listen to you guys all the time no
joke
good energies like love all you guys the
new sets i didn't compliment it when it
first came in
because it was so uh hustle and bustle
but dig it it's got a very see this it's
got a peach pit vibe to it what's that
saudi arabia is slowly killing my father
you know just randomly
that was my high school yearbook
where can they find you next man we got
the rock show dropping soon rock show
young rock i play the rocks left nut
uh it's coming out that's a good part
coming out of
pretty them the big part of his tank
february 16th that's on nbc and then i
have a crowd work album that i put out
called i'll take it from here that's
on all the album places and uh what's
coming up
austin dallas in march um tacoma comedy
club in uh february
um you guys have done that right i've
done that yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah cool
room right great yeah great club have
you done
uh their other uh was it i haven't done
the bricktown one yet breakdown's great
it is
spokane that's cool yeah spokane well
caine's a cd spot but it's good that
there's a club there yes i mean it's
just literally like
meth and burritos everywhere
shout out to the owner of methane
burritos
um yeah but uh uh so austin dallas
seattle and then uh hopefully some more
spots you know
things are opening up man yeah uh and
then instagram adam right comedy
and uh and uh i think that's fun and
then you know [ __ ] uh
see me on uh you know chappelle's
instagram uh
trying to feed him pictures of julia
white yeah so we're gonna be great yeah
we'll get him we'll get you guys
watching i'll just link you guys through
text and you can just fan out
but how would you like how would you
like the intro to happen you know that'd
be dope yeah yeah
i don't know don't connect with any dude
dude i didn't know you were 39 you
totally look 38.
how's your son doing i bet he's all
just playing man i'll talk to you
tomorrow talk to you tomorrow
it's one a.m in that life yeah yeah um
yeah that'd be great
yeah yeah oh and uh and i'm doing this
um
uh uh virtual show that i'm putting on
for this food bank in seattle called
northwest harvest
and um it's uh just all the proceeds go
to benefit it all the proceeds go to
meth and burritos
yeah it's uh so the lineup is dana
carvey uh joel mchale
uh sue bird from the seattle storm uh
tom lennon adam devine eliza schlesinger
ron funches
my boy joy mcintyre from new kids on the
block google dolls and this band called
the head in the heart
and um oh my god
how do you like all this yeah early 90s
jewish music what other white stuff do
you have for us
wait doesn't derek also have like a big
uh affection for
like he's hauling oats or some [ __ ] no i
like it
no who is it no
is that with the way is it it's you it's
him with always no maybe it's
no chappelle no no it's chappelle with
ombro shorts do you have any of those
anything just super white um bro shorts
yeah yeah i remember those
old school man wow yeah if anyone's got
a pair wait so what got you into the goo
dolls uh i'm a fan of oasis that's my
that's what you like google dolls too
like yeah they're tight yeah this is
what got me in the google dolls
so this movie one of my favorite movies
i think i'm gonna get out of here
i gotta be honest man just started that
sense i was like i'm already late but i
don't know if i got time for this
i don't want to hear it
[Applause]
and your brain just goes i gotta get out
of here
what time is it hey
happy birthday man
[Applause]
i was like well that's my title yeah uh
hi brother i love you guys so much
thank you so awesome yeah congrats on
the engagement all that stuff yeah
congrats on the engagement man
yeah lucky fella be good yeah have a
good day
yeah i still got your number well adam
left and we ate hell and raised for
chappelle's
b day you tried the hot you only got
through a quarter of it but
listen i can't eat that thing fast no no
too hot
yeah but it's good hot yeah now it's
good now it got
mild and he's [ __ ] dying
he's a hole in his head don't do well
with hot i don't do well without at all
oh your voice okay yeah look at him i'm
good okay you all right
you holding your lips out and [ __ ] like
i'm surprised adam didn't take a
sandwich with them
what is it what's their left hand we
should say that
what oh there's more there's one
leftover yeah i like food yeah he did
grab it i was like
oh i thought he was going too i thought
he was too
that's not something you want to eat
before you got to go on set oh that's
right
you don't know no unless you're a
champion of just spicy if you eat the
real hot when your stomach's not going
to be
right yeah for the rest of the day i
think you've been have you done the
extra hot
that's what i ate hot yeah yeah i did i
did extra hot with my girl
it's hot hot hot how
have i done howling i don't think you've
done helen before i think you i remember
you telling me the spiciest
you went to was extra hot in pasadena
and then today is that's where it's at
oh different yeah there's two locations
there oh gotta get it
um i don't think i don't think i don't
think you should eat this before 12 p.m
like it should be like a three o'clock
four o'clock thing this is
it's just you get your stomach yeah do a
food truck after this
with cody garber it's donuts though i
[ __ ] hate when they book like donut
or like churros like if i'm the fighter
i'm like what
yeah the [ __ ] is this you want to end
with the churro you don't want something
you want i don't want to fly to la do an
interview over churro yeah i don't know
why they booked those
food trucks what's that you know what
it's called i don't know donuts are us
or something they might have actually
cracked
one you had crab cakes were [ __ ] oh
it was so great that made me sick
you like the chicken wing ones too
chicken wings my favorite what was that
i forget what it's called great chicken
wings
damn like jt's
not as good as jt's but good you love
yourself
nothing better right nothing better so
damn good best chicken wing i've ever
had
well close your mouth your mouth's
burning huh yeah yeah he can't even hold
me
it's like man i'm not the only one who
can it's like pretty i'm pretty sure
viewers
i can't stop brewers just just take the
night yeah yeah
just take the next round off all right
let's go to colonel evans what do you
got
here's the first one okay so have you
guys seen jennifer
lawrence jlo's uh performance at the
inauguration
no which is like america
america let's get loud let's get
loud yes
so she did a mashup of two songs i
believe it's america the beautiful
and this is your land and towards the
very end of her performance
she says she did basically what you did
and that is a lyric to one of her songs
and people started roasting her on
twitter
quickly afterwards because it felt very
self-serving yeah
[Music]
yeah we don't need you to throw in your
own lyrics into this [ __ ]
is this a new song by her let's get loud
yes no it's a
like one for classics oh is it let's get
loud as an older one
heard that let's get loud let's get
laughs
do we have a video of it yeah yeah is it
like in the very end uh
close to the yeah okay
she's fine as hell though
in her 50s a little more further
[Applause]
[Laughter]
staying let's get that it's just a weird
like self promo yeah you're also j.lo
yeah you don't need to do that you know
i'll tell you what though
you people clown on a performance in the
new year's eve performance
her agent popping though he has her
doing that
this oh yeah this [ __ ] probably being
the super ball who knows you know agent
is killing as well demi lovatos
she was that she performed we've seen
her in a while huh she did uh
she saw the national anthem she did the
super bowl she did
i mean they they had like a whole bro
anthem where
at the inauguration oh she did yeah
lovato did you
bro put up all her dimmies she had that
song she had that weird trump song
she said mr president she's fine as [ __ ]
to me and so talented
she she should be going through some
[ __ ] like a while back i thought it was
katy perry
no that's that's demi lova yeah she
looks like kitty though i know katy
perry did it too though
like she's been booking her agent is
killing her she did the super bowl she
can
say yeah she's great though
did you see bernie sanders she bought it
up yeah
we have that as a current event too oh
bernie that thing that's going on
you don't that's not a current event
which one demi lovato being bodybuilders
now we all know that
oh bodybuilders we talked about it
before what else do you do
no yeah multiple times okay so
the miami heat arena is gonna i believe
it's the att arena
they are gonna let fans start to come in
and watch the games but
in order for you to go in you're gonna
have to have a dog that has been trained
to detect
covid like basically these dogs damn i
don't know that's why i saw and i i was
so confused i didn't know you can
train dogs to sniff out coven yeah so i
heard about this the dog yeah they can
smell covet yeah
i wonder how legit it is yeah yeah but
what if i get some beef jerk in my bag
and he starts freaking out
well they train them not to go for that
[ __ ] ah
dogs jerky yeah they go crazy what does
kovac smell like
i don't know but they can't oh that's
true like does it have a center yeah
that's what i'm saying because i'm like
hold on i could have been detect a
couple of things
that's crazy man that's cool though i
think you're right you know how pissed
you'd be
if you're going the game with your girl
and the dog starts barking
like [ __ ] i got courtside
what are you doing that situation do you
do you go with her because you gotta
leave or do you stay to watch
uh i'm watching the game okay well i'm
watching it again
okay easier way to get a covet test have
a dog sniff you out and i'm like okay
you're good you're good
yeah i wonder what the success rate of
the dog is right
i'm so weird
what else we got that one this one
okay so you talked about it last episode
where joe exotic had a huge stretch
limo waiting for him outside of prison
but he didn't get pardoned by trump
so he came out in a series of tweets and
it's not him tweeting it it's his people
tweeting on his behalf and he basically
says that he was too innocent
and too gay to deserve a pardon from
trump and then he starts to say that
donald trump jr was the only one who
cared and he only cared for social media
clout oh he's saying trump used him
as like yeah exactly and then he also
says
that the stretch limo that he got was
not
it was for him but he did not rent it
like all those like little publicity
stunts yeah that people were working
it's a distraction from really what's
going on but i don't know
yeah i don't know he so he's in prison
because uh he hired somebody to kill
homegirl yeah that's right yeah but then
they found like him killing
animals as well yeah shot tigers in the
head supposedly
22 year sentence man right that old was
that a dodge durango it looks kind of
cool though
yeah the back is a party there ain't no
cool
no limo is popping anymore that's such
an old-school vegas thing
it looked like a fort like a truck it's
a dodge durango they had a sign of
pardon joe exotic
yeah he probably had nothing to do with
that they did say he had hair and makeup
ready to go though for him
that's embarrassing man he in there yo
that jacket is still like one of his
most fashionable statements that emt
jacket the emt jacket though
he came out there
so funny uh so shout out to our boy
brandon schaub
he made the list of the best buffalo
players to wear a number
my brother sent me this okay let's check
it out
insane they need to come and see who
else was number 43.
i'll tell you where this i am full back
right there
best ever to wear it i'm trying to get
other 43s
my boy klopp got [ __ ] because klopp's
one of the best players to ever play at
university colorado
his problem is he's number 89 before him
was a guy named daniel
graham who won the mackey award who's a
super baller in the nfl too
and in the uh college so klopp's
on the list oh he's not on the list no
because there's only one for each number
see 89 daniel graham was a super baller
super baller so you held it down for 43.
held down 43.
they retire your jersey no i don't think
they're retired
no i don't know if they retired
anybody's maybe uh
this guy did i forget his name whitey
something they might retire his now did
a lot of these cats make it into the
pro i would say 98 percent of that
oh nfl yeah that's dope
christian fury was a beast keith english
beast you you played with a lot of
beasts right oh yeah
yeah like 13 of our seniors uh went to
the nfl
[ __ ] john embry b snake soldier super
beast
wait michael westbrook d michael
westbrook from oh i'm thinking i got
uh from philadelphia he didn't go to
philly yeah yeah oh he played he got
drafted by washington he's the one who
caught the
the hell married in the michigan game
okay that's what i'm talking about
cornell stewart throwing the ball
oh bro it's damn i know you went to
buffalo i'm back
yeah yeah there's some monsters on that
list
cool shout out to brendan shaw man shout
out to the show
that was surprising yeah do you have
your uh jersey from college
my dad does oh he has it oh he has it
framed in his uh basement
oh that's sweet that's the original one
the one that the original yeah yeah
it has a logo it has a big patch on it
from
either the houston ball or the tangerine
ball when we played clemson
yeah did you win uh we lost clemson and
that was weird because
after that that that's when like clemson
became clemson after that
and our program went like this and they
went like this took off yeah
it was weird that was the game where
they just [ __ ] skyrocketed and then
our we're back now we're like we were
top 10 this year but before that there
were some rough years
it's weird they like went you know
better took us yeah we went down as well
all recruits oh and you won bowl games
we won bowl games yeah
how many do you what three we won yeah
we won the houston ball against utap
and then we played in three big 12
championships
lost in the big 12 championships i got
rings though still you got
rings though i got your rings okay
that's cool yeah i'll bring it i know
it's a ring ceremony who
your boy sent us uh a buffalo bills yeah
yeah mm-hmm that was dope i know don't
have to i told her
i was like i was like if you if you find
one like grab it off of him
oh yeah it'd be good yeah i'll send you
money for that yeah
what else you got jen all right my buddy
joey sent me this it's the uh
security detail for joe biden do you
know who the head is
you don't it's a korean dude
his name is david cho let me see if i
can get his picture right there
he's the korean american yeah he's most
likely going to be the head like i guess
they're still in the transitional thing
because he was working for trump before
too
he was like the guy that was in charge
of north korea when trump went to north
korea
the security there that's a tough
internet yeah dude so this guy's like
he's quite a badass yeah what's
interesting is
uh so you know trump for the rest of his
life has secret service with him to
protect him
and then for the the next six years the
or i think it's six years it might be
six months
they his fan he can like give it to his
family so his kids have
uh secret service for the next six
months six months
i'm pretty sure it's six months damn not
for life though yeah that could get
dicey after six months
after six months you're like oh hey i
don't want you guys to leave yeah
because
and then what i was reading that yeah
and the vice president only has it for
six months it's like pence has it for
six months
no then after that's on you doug damn
but but all former presidents get it for
life
so much money taxes yeah for that think
of that that's a lot
and it's like well and then and then
like and then when you're president you
can
your family's covered so like obama's
daughters are covered
trump's kids were covered but now that
like once
obama stopped like now his kids are
still covered
but he has to pay for it i think though
oh god that camera
yeah i was like i wonder how much that
[ __ ] is doug cannot be cheap
yeah so free at six months yeah see like
think of takashi six nine
let's pay for his own security a ton do
you see homeboy
did you guys see a world star you see on
world story he was at he was like doing
paintballing you know
he's still a kid yeah so he's like
having fun doing babylon and some random
dude at the paintball place started
talking [ __ ] to him
it was like wayne outside started
talking [ __ ] to him you see what
happened no his security
beat the [ __ ] knocked him out let's pull
this up i got to see it he said it's on
our world star hip-hop champion let's
see hold on
i'm sure it'll be brought up see he's
only 24. worth eight dude worth eight
million
that's what he says he's young young and
stupid yeah
so [ __ ] young but on his documentary
hey hear me out here
so the hip-hop
urban community backs little wayne when
he when he was like yeah
i sided with trump so i'd get pardoned
so i'd have to go to prison everyone's
like hell yeah i'll do the same thing
yeah takashi six nine snitches on them
did what he had to do to get out of
prison everyone's like nah [ __ ] that
that's a rat it's like is that not the
similar thing all right let me let me
just break it down i mean granted he put
other people out chris about to say
but but did he not put criminals in
prison but he was also trolling no like
let's say someone
like king mon died right yeah a real
street
chicago rapper he put a a laughing emoji
for sure now lil wayne don't do a
disrespect like that but that's the but
but my thing is is like if if uh
the hip-hop community or urban community
whatever's the best way to say it if
they're if you're cool with little wayne
and kodak black
doing whatever they need to do to avoid
prisons what are they black didn't
snitch
i don't know what he did oh okay no i'm
saying but he he's with trump
trump pardon carter so if you're going
to support him and do whatever it takes
even though you don't
you really you don't [ __ ] with him
you're just doing to avoid your 10-year
prison time
and everyone's like yeah tight move i do
the same thing [ __ ] him dude
and then but when it comes to akashi
nine everyone's like dude he's a [ __ ]
sport cause i don't think don't work
with him i don't think people ever liked
him
takashi yeah so this just like it's like
like the peers
look like little waynes yeah yeah but
like with takashi
i don't think the peers liked him yeah
but but for that but [ __ ] he does yeah
like
yeah the trolling before yeah before the
snitching and [ __ ] like
i think they still hate it it was built
up yeah you're right
that's good that's the point yeah but
but a lot of people didn't uh roll with
lil wayne
a lot of people don't mess with lil
wayne yeah come on come on
but that's like now anybody that like
anybody like people love little ones
like uh who was it uh nicki minaj works
with
the album like nicki minaj was uh six
nine she did a song with him dude people
are furious yeah i know but
if you do a song away legend
legend yeah his like his resume is
different
legend legend super legends you know
what i mean
the point is people hated from the jump
from the jungle the snitching just
adds to it yeah you know again
antagonizing and just but i'm just
saying but it's weird for me that we're
cool with
this because we like this guy but he
kind of did the same thing
well wayne did he did whatever it took
he didn't any nice
you know lil wayne was just like i'm
gonna hit him yeah yeah he was yeah the
costume yeah
yeah doing all the beef [ __ ] yeah so i
get what you're saying oh you have the
video of him
yeah oh yeah let's see that i want to
see it oh yeah it's a takashi one kicks
him right in the face
oh
look at that look at that bro did he
not think there's a white guy going look
at that look at him
the group yeah no j-shop's got kicking
him in the face
that's what you'd have to worry about
with jay the jay shot that's not his
bodyguard i look like he's homey though
no he said bodyguards
oh she said right yeah yeah how did that
guy not think that was going to happen
like what do you think she is protected
yeah man
you think someone one of his dudes ain't
gonna pop you for talking [ __ ] to him
something there's no way takashi just
gets off scot-free something's gonna
happen
investigation oh what wait what happened
wait is this an old one battery
what what the hell there's no way you
call it he's still doing crime you
called it there's no way
you called it no involved apostles
strong armed robbery
dude you got eight million why are you
still trying to be hard
i don't get it man yeah it is weird
insane to you i know you just how do you
not learn your lesson well and the fats
are all over you dude
it's so frustrating you remember we
played that video him and tank davis
getting into it i think he's still want
to be
part of that at the atlanta club just be
live your life bro
damn yeah what do you have to be a
gangster about we already know you're
not come on man just chill out
yikes get into a fight oh dragon bogus
stronger
there you go okay i'm sure there's me
fake news after an investigation
made up most of the story oh yeah
okay yes we rapper has been cleared hey
what's that [ __ ] dancing
oh yeah trey
what else you got jen um lamar odom we
have
some footage of him hitting mitts all
right let's see it
i want to see it and the way they
describe this too crush's boxing
training session
is that churchill boxing i think that is
dude
i don't know oh no that's kevin hart and
listen to the music in the background
yeah that's that is kevin hart's
training atlanta it's elevator music
it's so weird yeah it's so strange well
i can't even talk [ __ ] because no it's
so bad it's
it's i wasn't even looking at his
punches my bad you know it's so
cool it's so slow
why he hunched over like oh dude who's
he gonna fight
they say i'll be named boy look how big
his feet are look how big his feet are
huge
bro got the malik legs
go to my instagram there's a video be uh
punching at the top of the mountain
that's just like punching the top of the
mountain yeah but you're not trying to
fight
yeah it's my story right yeah it's my
story
look at that dude better than lamar
oh you think so yes yeah i mean neither
one of you is using your hips but
still i don't know what that is still
better look at that look at that
why were you up there shadow boxing uh
because i made it to the [ __ ] top
that was your rocky moment that was my
problem you started shadow boxing
because of rocky
oh hell no who put that scroll back oh
someone tagged the uh
he's a meme now that's hilarious who is
lamar odom fighting though they did not
announce that what dumbass is gonna
[ __ ]
do that someone who sees lamar odom like
all right yeah i'll take a million
cat any update on your only fans yeah
what's up with them feet uh
what did you think you got my girl going
how much do you make i know
my girl goes you know which man i can
make with this ass like [ __ ]
your girl would make a cute yeah don't
encourage this
she would be the money maker of your
household
too yeah we're not doing bro
your girl is [ __ ] beautiful we are
not um you don't want to do it you
you don't want to see you get those tits
out on the ground
here's the thing though the workout like
videos that she puts on instagram is
more than enough
so she could just just check that out
yeah on only fans
oh really yeah because my i found out
that people
don't even necessarily want to see nudes
they want to see like thirst trap stuff
like stuff that girls would post on
their instagram stories of like oh i'm
going to go out with the girls like
my tits are kind of out my ass is kind
of out but it goes on your shoulders
she could do that i guess like a kid a
bad luck i feel like
for who you are to the whole family
although she's great
yeah she wants to buy a daddy a new ride
would you let your girl juice up that
camp name
would you let your girl do it uh what
were we doing that's what
because my girl goes how much can i yeah
yeah she probably quit doing the show in
a month
yeah how much now uh uh we get edited
can we edit this out
uh yeah yeah how much is just the the
money oh okay i make uh right now i have
four days what am i in 12 days in four
days in four days
cat eddie says out cat let me edit do
you make go beep beep because it's gonna
help your
also don't uh show my lips because they
can read lips show mine
yeah yeah so our face was exposed why my
god
well how long before you quit kat i'm
not leaving the show
are you sure bro no booster only fans
it's one it boosts my only fans and two
i love being here
the stomach's on fire oh are you okay
yeah
and then or just
are you gonna move huh uh well i have a
lease for a while i don't think i'm
gonna change much in my life
even after the money yeah
ferrari in like three months like at the
top of the year
it's still like we still like kind of
like locked down this is my idea
[Music]
is stevie like this is definitely very
happy
because now you know no he i could be a
sugar mama if i wanted to
you're a sugar mama stevie's a shirt
have i got a 20 can i be a six figure
queen now malik
is this oh god your shakespeare if you
keep it up for the next ten months
you're six figures
yeah exciting it's only up from here
only it's on you if it
goes if it [ __ ] up holy get it
i told my girl she hit you with the good
for you yeah
joanna was like oh hell yeah yeah she
was like really would you like that's
the thing like only fans was kind of
weird at the beginning because it was
only kind of like nudes and sex work but
now
like after the whole bella thorne thing
it's really just like girls not posting
on their instagram stories anymore and
putting it on there is your sister gonna
try a certain one too or no uh well
right now she hates work
so she's like damn you're making that
much money real quick she's kind of
thinking about it meanwhile i got an eye
doctor for me
i think she's waiting for uh to see if
like the love island thing is gonna work
out
also she should do it before she gets on
there don't wait till you get off the
level island
you never know if it'll affect it or not
like no they don't i mean
they won't give up also apparently love
island here in the us
like they don't have a lot of hot guys
trying to like get on the show
like they're looking for hot guys right
busted so if you want to date my sister
submit to love island and you might get
a chance yeah
that might be the easiest thing well i'm
getting bigger so i figured
yeah i thought you were acting a little
different you see how gracious
you came and stevie stops responding
yes i'm like dude
he's been using us oh my god
did he use you guys to get to me
and now i'm my only fans i'm going to
have a fake ass in three months yeah
wild wait so you're you're young and
you're a sugar mama already
25. i'm technically not a sugar mom
because i'm not spending money on him
and i just started making this money
four days ago
so it's still fairly new but the options
there new money great
all right new money i like having the
office what's your favorite what you
call them the cat squad
uh you call it the cat squad a bunch of
people already
uh asking for merch in the only fans
it's like oh yeah
you could do it all yeah i could do it
all the world is yours could also help
you with merch cap
he could yeah and your sister name is
cat right
yeah both of our names well we both go
by cat i'm captain she's cat full
okay cool yeah
like american pronunciation but her name
is gekko
mine is
i rewatched our clip what you think
about java room sounds probably
come on man you can have that meow
[Music]
what about you are you starting yours
now nice you know all that money is
coming i'm starting to listen and i'm
thinking about things i have to do so
you posted a mind you got to show that
dangling
i did you posted a picture yeah almost
there yeah you have to get your tits out
yeah get your ding-a-ling and your tits
out
yeah probably not though but probably
not
probably not no one wants to see an
asian dude
i mean yeah you don't know you know how
many sponsorships you can get
if i was like if i was ripped away
here let's not get carried away here
like he's cat or something hey
girl we've been telling cat for hot
seconds hey girls have fetishes
uh we do but girls usually don't pay for
them yeah
that's the thing like girls never have
to go out of their way to pay for stuff
like that
no girls
absolutely do not have to like if you
look hard enough there's a man who's
willing to do whatever kinky fetish
thing you want
hmm if you're a girl regardless of like
weight
age how you look there is a man out
there willing to do it but it's also a
market for women paying for dudes though
yeah there is not that big though some
people just want to pay other people to
do things for them
yeah is what i found cat you a champion
thank you
mm-hmm look into it if i do it it's
gotta be some talent based
didn't he say please naked i don't even
make it though
it has to be a harmonica
i wanna do the no no i harmonica want
the helmet i'm gonna order an
uh harmonica i'm gonna start learning
how to get the one with the the thing on
the neck
yeah so i could play you play guitar
yeah yeah yeah yeah look at the bernie
look like somebody hunty
yeah so this dude just uh they're
talking with a bunch of friends they
know how to do this stuff right yeah
graphic design all that stuff so they
were just talking about it they created
a website and this thing just took over
the world everyone everyone's doing the
burning meme though
which has been hilarious i put them on
google maps like just different places
i'll put them on right there
they go we get another [ __ ] over skype
[Laughter]
c1 is good the u.s i think rogan posted
oh the one of him like
there's walmart
it's not rogan's yeah hilarious
oops not that damn
my stomach on fire right now bro well
there he finally got that
kid on i think he's done his story oh
story yeah this morning
let's take a look oh there it is
that's fantastic that's hilarious
that's so funny um
do you guys remember seeing this a a
little while ago
yeah like the pilots were saying that
they saw someone in a jet pack flying up
like 3000 feet in the air
lax right yeah so it turns out it's most
likely which i'm sure it is it's a it's
a drone
with a mannequin on it oh like that oh
that was so unwanted to see what would
happen if they flew over the airport it
was a trial run
yeah shouldn't that [ __ ] got shot down
or something oh man you're getting so
much trouble feeling yeah
yeah you could still get in trouble if
it's a mannequin no
yeah yeah like even just flying a drone
in that area yeah
you'll get in trouble yeah yeah yeah it
was near lax right yeah yeah
but then they said this one's from
germany so i don't know how that works
out maybe someone else made
something similar interesting and
speaking of germany
this is this looks super cool so german
scientists were able to bring
mice that had you know nerve damage
where they couldn't walk anywhere
they're paralyzed
they regenerated those nerves and
brought it back so they can walk within
like three weeks
that's [ __ ] insane so they're doing
our rats first then they want to move
over to bigger things like pigs
and then potentially human beings dude
if my legs don't work i i
i'm lieutenant dan i would sign up with
this dude this is amazing it's
incredible
this [ __ ] is dope lieutenant dan
lieutenant you got a new leg
they gave you
the purple heart of metal they gave you
and then he goes down the snow he's all
whoa
he's going backwards so lieutenant dan
runs after him
and that's it all right awesome happy
birthday chappelle
thank you happy birthday thank you guys
i appreciate it man
you guys already doing this show with
you 32 34 right
34 34. yeah what are you doing tonight
watching my feet
shut them up shut them up
i don't know why it's so stupid but it
[ __ ] pops in my head like any time
i'm doing it
so stupid every time i go in the
restrooms you go walk your feet
i don't know why
yeah we got to be at the club in like yo
15 minutes he was like okay cool
chappelle what you going to do
you better leave what are you doing
because your birthday's tomorrow
yeah you know i'm not a girl i'm not a
big uh you know like i don't
your girls can do something though yes
it's red panda night yeah it's rampant
it's red tonight you know what i'm
saying come on man the only fan
where are you gonna get that lube out
from the mallet
you're gonna borrow some blue for mel
yeah i got it on deck everybody's
[ __ ]
the thick boy commercial launched this
oh let's watch it yeah
everyone here watch it with the mute
with the music on
oh yeah that's my are you gonna
copyright us i'm gonna i'm gonna flag it
and
just post the show down
hey all my life i've been told
i promise i like it i promise
the dream was to make it to the nfl with
that lane closed
heartbreaking i decided to fight grown
men and still cage my underwear
and it was tough so i found podcasting
which led me into stand-up comedy
ain't life grand through this journey i
realized
[Music]
doesn't consist of a cash prize it's a
donut i've been thinking all goddamn day
about
so i've come to the conclusion i'm not
the only thick boy in the world
there's a lot of us a whole lot of us
which is why i start a club
a safe space you don't have to kill
yourself dieting
we don't post shirtless selfies no
matter how many miles we put in
we stay this
[Applause]
it's cool i saw somebody at my gym
yesterday wearing a thick boy shirt love
it
damn bro you're out here then chen uh
did the post
uh we went on instagram and the tags
it's up to like 5.5
big boy oh yeah how many people do the
hashtag big boy
yeah yeah that's great man shout out to
all the thinkies specialized collab
is out now son uh thickboy.com for the
collab the smiley they got it all there
update that page
they better be on there there we go
there it is look at there it is
i got some [ __ ] bro that now that body
not included
i don't know what model they use that's
cool not included body not included
there it is though kids.com buddy
next week man friday saturday uh there's
probably 10 tickets left for all the
shows
some are sold out so san marcos texas
next week get tickets now
f-a-t-k-z.com or t-fatkay.com wherever
you want to get your tickets
and next date for us is tampa florida
february 26
through the 27th get your tickets tampa
florida ya up san marcos next week can't
wait
i'll be on rogan as well so stay tuned
for that
that's it kids that's it man happy
birthday chappelle happy birthday
happy 35th just kidding buddy
there's cats i need some water should
you get a picture of him eating my
sandwich
i'm getting the videotape right now give
him a picture i eat mine it's still hot
it's still hot so malach has mild
brendan has hot look at that
look at that look at that you took a
juicy bite dude
it's not a chicken sandwich look at that
is it otter
what are you serious
no not how they're mine you you're hot
yours is hot
mine is like a little bit below and it's
hot though
yours is comparable to burnings medium
with the kick
medium and then mild like this his is
not affecting me right now
i'm already [ __ ] up from the miles but
you also have a low
uh low spice tolerance
so i feel like any spikes would have
[ __ ] you up i'm gonna get water
your grandma's gonna i'll give them out
i wouldn't say that's mild
okay thank you it might be a holland
raised mom though yeah
all right what's up man chappelle lacy
always getting crazy but never high off
that spacey you know what i'm saying
uh i just got these in the mail
yesterday jordan ones
uh the pink shadows to match that uh
love is tight hoodie you know what i'm
saying
match the color the love is tight get
the love assistant you get that and you
get this
all right yeah chappelle lacy.com for
these hoodies though now you know what
i'm saying
hey who took your dude i don't know
sample whiskey if i sign off on it it'll
get packaged and bottled when we drop it
in march
and there's mine that's your yeah and
this is my first ship in a long
set hot second and what you rocking
brendan
oh these these little these old things
these okay
talking about these old things off
whites off white air force ones
these bite in air force ones
looking like a sick jose canseco
cheers yeah what's up we got the waves
oh the white chick
where is your dude bro i will sit down
all the time
they're hitting hard in the back today
right yeah i got on the stussy collab
you know what i mean stucy with you
show them your stupid [ __ ] pants with
the knife
bro
yeah you see a little stussy right here
you see it he's saying
don't push me i'm all right yeah
oh i'm walking the kobe branches yeah
the kobe grinches these come out what
next
month hey now they're out they are
yeah well stockx right yeah but in the
stores they come on this